And now the old scout master
Man. I can't talk.
That's a
Yeah. no,
Go ahead, say a tongue.
Sorry, Mark,
He was on the tip of my tongue.
Yeah,
I got my tongue over my eye tooth and I couldn't see what I was saying.
Hey, really, it's alright,
I can talk.
This is podcast 92..
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
So this week is our monthly scout master panel discussion
And I'm going to be very brief in the introduction here.
I just want to take a look in the mailbag real quick.
Walter wrote in- not Walter Underwood, the other Walter-
and said I'm sitting on the train listening to podcast 91.
I'm laughing out loud.
Needless to say, the other writers are slowly moving away from me.
Well, that's one way to have a little privacy on the train.
I love your humor and I love the sound effects.
Thank you for the Brick Mason episode.
Thanks, Walter, for another vote of confidence in getting back in touch.
So far, you and I like the Brick Mason episodes.
That's about it.
Tom Dewey wrote in on the blog about podcast 91.
He said I thought you made your point very effectively
that scout master conferences and boards of review
are a conversation with the boy that can lead to his development as a scout.
Some are put off by the new black and white rules
and the guide to advancement that are in stark contrast
to the way that things have been done in their troop for a long time.
I hope that they won't be too resistant to change.
Thank you, Tom.
During the discussion that we had this week,
one of the things that we were all reflecting on
was how important this new guide to advancement is.
You're going to hear about that in just a moment.
There's been a lot of action this week over at the blog and on Facebook
and there's some more things to discuss.
Some of that I'm going to hold over until next week
because we have a great scout master panel discussion
with our first call-in question.
If you want to call in with a question to our next discussion,
just email me. Let me know.
We'll have all the different ways you can get in touch
towards the end of the podcast. Let's get started. shall we
Time for another scout master panel discussion?
So this week let's welcome our panel members: Larry Geiger
from Vera, Florida. Hey, Larry,
Hey Clark, I'm here.
Tom Glard from Tolahoma, Tennessee-
How are you, Tom?
Hi Clark
And Walter Underwood all the way out there
in Palo Alto, California. How are you doing, Walter
Howdy?
All three of these fellows are experienced scout masters
and we're here to discuss some things
I think you'll find helpful in your work as a scout leader.
There are three new publications
that have come out of the BSA recently.
You won't have to go digging for these documents, folks-
All of the things that we discussed during this podcast.
there'll be a link to a PDF version of the document
on the post at scoutmastercgcom.
So the first one is the new youth leader training guide:
Introduction to leadership skills for troops-
ILST.
Do you guys remember that as being called YLT at one point?
The last version was TLT- troop leadership training-
Okay,
And right before that it was youth leadership training
And then right before that it was JLT-
junior leader training.
I got a good look at the new training syllabus
And I generally liked it
Well. I read through it and it's almost exactly the same as TLT,
As far as I could tell. it had the edge section
and it had the other sections.
It's just fleshed out a little more.
How about you, Walter?
What did you think?
It's a lot easier to work with than TLT,
because there's more stuff there
And I like that. there's some alternatives for the games.
So if you do it twice a year,
you don't just run the same games into the ground.
I felt like it stopped halfway, though
The reflections are things like:
tell us some examples about servant leadership,
And it never says: what are you going to do,
Right,
And we just, you know, and our funny,
it's right. when this was published,
we had put together our own from bits and pieces
of former trainings
And we went pretty strongly towards
here, to responsibilities,
What are you going to do towards goals,
And it does feel kind of like the parts
you know this and the positions, responsibility stuff
and the new guide to advancement.
They're like they're not talking to each other
because this doesn't quite support that.
These feels like it needs another good round of work.
on the training,
What'd you come away with, Tom?
In general, I liked it a lot.
I'm like Walter. we've been looking for something
and I was going through and taking some of the stuff
from the old JLT that had the video clips
and the role play and all that stuff
and trying to put stuff together
and incorporate, edge and incorporate the methods of teaching,
and then this pops up
and it is a lot better than the TLT.
Like Larry said, it gives you a little more in-depth stuff.
I think
It gives you times, it breaks things down,
but I liked it enough. I hit print on the machine
and I've got a copy of it now.
High praise indeed.
We're going to attempt this one next month.
I do have to say we did use the old videos
and our guys loved them.
In fact, one of the new-
after the two guys fighting inside the tent
which just cracked them up,
Take it to the tent- is one of the new sayings from our leader.
Did you know? all those clips are on YouTube.
It's maybe where we got some of them.
I found all of them on YouTube
and that's how I was going to use them
was off of the YouTube stuff.
I've got the DVD that has all of them on there.
One thing about this thing:
and they've gone back to saying
no, we actually need to get the leaders together
and call it a course.
It actually says in here about this course.
I saw in the introduction too.
I saw some pretty good explanations
of the relationship of the scout master
to the youth leaders,
emphasizing that any youth leaders
that have been through the training
should be right up front in presenting.
I thought that was pretty positive.
When we do youth leader training with my troop,
we use an amalgam of a lot of different things.
What about you guys?
Start with you, Larry,
Do you have a syllabus that you created?
Okay, I have my own.
It's made up of doing district JLTs
and then TLTs
and then a whole bunch of other stuff
over the years.
I like to do at least one session a year.
I like to find a really nice conference room
with nice chairs
and we go somewhere and have a nice lunch
and in the morning about 10 o'clock
we stop and we bring out all the drinks
and it's kind of like a business seminar.
I do the whole thing during the day
for the scouts.
But then we also- like the last one we did
was more outdoor.
We were in a park, we had a building,
but I didn't do it.
The other guys, the new guys, did it,
but they did a lot more outdoor stuff
and they did some of the game type stuff.
Tom, what do you guys use generally
as a youth leader training tool?
Do you have your own thing that you kind of made up,
like Larry? or
We had been using the canned national,
the JLT, and then we started sharing.
There was another district was doing
one that they had made,
so we started sharing in with that
and they were putting that on.
Then we sort of got a little lax
and we were basically trying to do something internal
and it's not working out like we had hoped.
so we're trying to go back to something
with a little more structure
that we can see where we're supposed to be headed
instead of sort of making it up,
and I sort of like that a little bit.
Walter, you said you guys were in the middle
of kind of working on your own deal.
Right, we've followed the outline
of the troop leadership training,
TLT, but mostly with material from JLT courses
and then with some extra bits.
I thought it was interesting that they listed
the responsibilities of adult leaders,
because we did that.
We said here's what you can
and again a step further,
what you can expect from the adult leaders.
I think we'll pull in a bunch of stuff from this.
There's other sources too.
There's some great leadership games,
training from the UK
Scouts in the UK that we've looked at.
I think this has kind of got good bones,
but we'll flesh it out a little differently.
If we had 20 Scoutmasters here,
they would all say that they have
almost a unique approach
where they cobble something together
with different things that they've used in the past.
It starts getting stale if you use
the same thing every year,
So you have to start mixing it up somehow
And I don't know.
that's where you use your older Scouts
that have been through it.
You use them for staff
and then more involved trying to do that,
But it just takes a lot of effort to do that.
Most of you will know, if you've been reading the blog
and listening to the podcast,
that within the past month or so,
the Boy Scouts of America
has also put out a new guide to advancement.
We're not going to try and pick apart
the whole guide to advancement
and look at everything,
but I'm sure it's something that we'll be spending
some time on during these discussions.
One of the things that changed,
through clarification
and maybe a couple of subtle changes,
was the positions of responsibility section.
But there was a couple of statements
in the guide that cleared up
a lot of common misconceptions about
whether or not you could hold
two leadership positions and double it up,
or whether if you weren't a leader
for a couple of months,
if that kind of exed out
some of the past stuff you'd done.
We never understood how people
it just I don't know.
We never did that,
We always. if they skipped
a month or two, that's fine.
They pick it up and it counts.
It starts counting then,
but we don't make them start at zero again.
It's always been time and grade.
I mean, serve for six months
is served for six months,
whether it's three here and three there,
And if it's two at the same time, it's still
Well. what if your troop
decides to have three month terms
and you need six months
and you never get two in a row?
That just doesn't make any sense.
Well, now it's very clearly spelled out
and that's one of the things I think
it's very positive in the new guide.
That's good.
There's been a lot of talk back and forth
about another section
and that is meeting unit expectations,
Because the guide
mentions unit expectations a couple of times
and it's been widely interpreted
as being
some of those metrics
that a lot of people use to apply
to Scouts
for being active or serving actively
in a leadership position.
When I say metrics, I mean
make at least 75% of meetings
or 10% of outings
or whatever people come up with,
Something I've never been too fond of
and I was wondering what everybody's thoughts were about that.
Was that?
I think that's a mistake.
I'm not actually going to work
against where they want to go,
but that's my opinion.
I think some people are going to read that
and go: oh well, our unit doesn't have any.
They're going to start writing policies
and, like you said,
that can just go on forever
and I think it's a mistake. but
Can't you get the youth involved
and ask them
what their expectation of the job should be?
The adults have an expectation,
The youth should have an expectation.
Where is the middle ground here?
Wouldn't that be a good idea?
Well, that's part of the mistake
to me is they don't mention the Scouts.
In my opinion,
if they elect a senior patrol leader
and six months later,
when they have another election,
if he's still the senior patrol leader,
then that's it.
As I said in one blog post,
if they come to me and say
a scout master says, well,
we've got a problem.
The two times that's happened to me
they've said: well, we think we ought to do this.
I said, well, it's your troop.
and they go and do it
and in both situations
they did the right thing. I think
I just don't see it being up to us.
They elect the guys.
I dealt with this once.
We had someone who was a scribe
and just didn't show up to the PLC meetings
to take notes, and that's
pretty much not doing the job.
Back then the only thing I could find
was that the scout master
should remove
a scout from the position
if they're not filling the responsibilities,
and that was on an FAQ
about that on the scouting site.
That's a mess.
How long do you wait until you remove someone?
I think this is
clear. You say
you have to tell people the responsibilities
at the beginning
or you don't get to
measure them on those
expectations at the end of their term.
That's completely fair
and it's really a lot like
jobs where you say
here's what's expected
and if you settle that
reasonable expectations in your troop,
I think that's a healthy thing to get going.
If you have unreasonable expectations,
well, people should.
I think Larry probably found the one element
in that section that seems to be missing
and that is: what part
do the scouts have in making those determinations?
in the language that they use
just seems to put it all in the lap of the scout master.
That has a possible
negative effect, let's say,
depending on the scout master.
But I think, Tom, you had it just right.
If we're going to set reasonable expectations,
are we just going to set them and show them to the boys
or are they going to be part of
making that up Somewhere else?
in there? it says you can't.
you can't block items at the six month period.
You can't say, oh, you weren't here
so you don't get credit.
Well, isn't that part of
a possible scout master
conference intermediate,
to talk to them and find out
why aren't you here?
I know that's part of the senior patrol
leaders duty also, but you can
sort of intervene and,
like you've always said,
they're going to be more
down on themselves and you could ever be,
But just sort of
find out what the deal is.
What I think is important is
there is a language in there- is that
you can't ambush a scout
If you haven't done your job
and you haven't kept up with them and talked to them
and had an ongoing conversation
with them. you can't get to month number
six and say, oh, by the way,
I didn't tell you this but you
really didn't qualify on that.
The third publication that we've seen
in the past couple of months- that
is new- is a revision
of the Eagle Project workbook.
Walter, you've got some special interest in that.
you did a blog post for us about it.
What is your role there?
that makes you interested in the Eagle Project
workbook? Well, I've been invited to be
part of the district advancement committee
so I can approve Eagle Projects.
I've approved a whopping three of them
so far, but
as soon as I was trained
they changed the rules.
It's great to have everything in one place
and to have it so clear
because it was spread out everywhere.
and the other thing
is that there's a real
change towards
the adult. leaders are now.
their job is
to really assist
scouts who are working on
Eagle and not to put up roadblocks.
We're not asking them to be
perfect, We're asking them to
improve towards being responsible
citizens, and
I think it's a great
change in focus.
I have one big like about
the Eagle Project workbook
Locally here. our Eagle Project
workbook that was distributed by the council
had a whole bunch of stuff
folded into it,
But now people can't do that.
I was surprised to hear
that because we never-
the
our council never- did that. We always
went by that
booklet and I was surprised
to hear that
I generally don't use the workbook,
I show it to the scouts.
Basically it's a list
and my scouts have written
their Eagle Projects
like an essay and everyone's different.
All the same things:
the signature page, the approval here, the list,
that's all there. but
they've kind of written it up their own way generally
and I really like that.
Walter, in your opinion, does
this take
away the ability of a scout
to do whatever he likes
in the way that he presents an Eagle Project?
I think the new workbook gives
the more guidance on
what to do
and it focuses it that
your planning is really part of your leadership
as opposed to getting an approval,
because the planning is now
evaluated by your board of review.
So most
of the project workbooks I've seen
have write ups
which are in the form
requested by the workbook but are separate.
So there's a binder which has
the workbook pages, signatures
and then separate pages
which correspond
to the parts of the workbook.
So, Larry, if I understood your objection
properly, it was that
if everybody
was required to use the workbook
unchanged, that it would kind of
restrict scouts from
making these kind of work of art
project proposals.
Yeah, that's kind of how I read it.
it said that you had to use each page
exactly as it
has to look, exactly the same
as it does in the. there's a line
in there that kind of says that-
or I interpreted it that way.
My interpretation
is what Walter
just said would not be accepted.
Now I'm not trying to
contradict him, I'm just saying
that's how I read that one line
in there that said: you must use
this book of these pages,
these blocks, exactly
as they are, like that.
Did your council
or your district have their own
Eagle Project workbook? No,
Walter, did your district
or council have their own Eagle Project
workbook or an amended one? Our council,
in fact, has not had their own
workbook and it's really
fairly close to the current process-
a few tweaks, but we're actually
pretty close. Like I said,
we had one that got amended
and it was pages and pages of stuff
and it was presented
to our scouts as the official
Eagle Scout project workbook.
Obviously, you guys haven't had that
problem and I
think that's where that language
came from, Larry- that
they didn't want anybody to alter
the workbook before it got into the hands
of the scout. Yeah, well, that's
okay. On the formality
side of the thing, I think
it is okay to
copy, and because you're not going to be able
to. you're not going to be able to put everything
in
all the words in those little blanks,
so you need to put it in a notebook.
but what?
when you are the
district advancement chairman
and you start getting all these
crazy,
crazy notebooks without
any kind of standardization, you
forget whether it's got this
item in it or whether it's got that
item, whereas if you sort of standardize
in your head,
you go, okay, there's that one, there's that one,
and you know, you can
remember that all the pieces
are there
and it's a lot easier
on him who has to see
we do
25, 30
Eagles a year is all we do,
but in our district-
but for a big district you could do a lot
more probably.
On page 2
it says the official fillable pdf version
can be found at:
although it is acceptable to copy and distribute
the workbook, it must maintain
the same appearance,
with nothing changed, added
or deleted.
so it appears
to me that you take this workbook
and either through the pdf
or through a copy, you write in:
exactly it's got
this page with the proposal,
the little boxes,
it's got materials
or things in the little
explanations with the
parentheses around it, all that stuff.
I kind of have a problem with that,
but that's me so
I just don't think they don't want
you just to adulterate it
in any manner.
add and subtract stuff like what Clark's
group has done.
I think the Scouts can still
basically get in whatever they want.
Walter, what other changes
did you see in the Eagle Scout process?
I think there's interesting
that the project workbook
is not a source of
a way to reject people,
things like not
delaying
to get to a reference.
there's just a lot of little things throughout it
and an explicit process
in case Scoutmasters refuse
to sign things.
you can go ahead and get a border of view
if you've ever encountered that,
like somebody get very doctor narrow
about something, seem to be deliberately
wanting to hold a Scout up for
some kind of administrative reason.
I did have a Scout join my troop
five years ago from another troop
because he was receiving that kind
of bogusness and he finished
his Eagle in my troop.
he was not going to become an Eagle Scout
for whatever other reasons
which I have never been able to figure out,
and so he came to our troop.
you know, fill out your plan
and we'll send it to the district.
and he did it, did his project,
did a good project finished it,
it was fine, but somebody had to be
in there, bonnet over in that other troop,
and I never talked to them. I didn't want to know
what Larry just described. I think you mentioned
in the post that you
wrote for the blog, Walter. you talked about
obstruction of Scoutmasters.
that sounds about right.
that's certainly what it sounds like to me.
have you seen that? experience that?
but I know that there
there can be a cult of Eagle,
which is
something wrapped up that's far beyond.
you know, this is a step
towards the rest of your life
instead of the pinnacle of everything.
anything else about the Eagle process
or anything you saw that you'd like to discuss.
Larry mentioned
or somebody said something about. it describes
in more detail and it really does.
I like that.
yeah, I think it's going to clear up a lot of
problems. the whole new guy-
I agree with you, Tom. well, fellas, we're
going to turn to the telephone. joining us
is David shoot, and David
has a question for the panel.
welcome to the Scoutmaster podcast, David,
thank you. where
are you in Scouting, David?
I'm in the Lehigh Valley in
Pennsylvania and what's your role there?
I'm the committee chair
with 59. I also
serve as a unit commissioner
for our district as well, and
you had a question that you wanted to
see if we could help you out with.
yeah, my question is: I took over
as committee chair back in January and
our committee was very inactive when I
started and unfortunately
that meant Scoutmaster had to do practically
everything. and
as the current committee chair, I'm trying to
help him out and I
want to do what I can, but I don't want to overstep
my bounds. so I was kind of wondering
where the Scoutmaster's responsibility
ends and the committee takes over.
well, we've got three guys
who've been in that role for a while, so
who'd like to begin?
okay, that sort of sounds like
when we first started the troop,
I was basically
it and I couldn't
wait to get out of that position,
out of trying to do stuff.
but right now
it's it is a committee
chairman and all the positions and
I just sit back and do my
my report when asked and
basically don't
talk about anything anymore. but
it took time to get there,
went
from an inactive
footing. it did take about how much time,
would you reckon, Tom?
about a year.
it took about probably a year for the
committee to really start getting
going and for me to be able to
really start backing off
quick. Larry, you had something to add there.
number one is finances,
obviously, number two
the committee chairman's responsible for
administration and the
Scoutmaster's responsible for the Scouts.
the committee's
responsible for advancement and boards of
review, the Scoutmaster's
responsible for Scoutmaster conferences.
the Scouts put together an
annual plan, the committee
with the Scoutmaster and the committee approves
it and agrees to support
it and fund it. you know, as you go down
that list and start breaking things apart,
there's some things that fall
pretty clearly on the committee
that the Scoutmaster shouldn't
even really have to worry about.
like Tom said, the finances
and the reservations
and the transportation coordination,
advancement, the advancement chairman-
that should not be an assistant Scoutmaster
or the Scoutmaster because
committee members have to do board. so
once you start kind of pulling
it apart and
the committee chairman begins to take
ownership of that, eventually
it should should just kind of fall out.
hopefully, for me it's.
it's like our church, the Episcopal
church, the, the priest is responsible
for the spiritual life of the congregation
and the vestry is responsible for the
money and buildings and other stuff, and it's like
that where the Scoutmaster is responsible for the
scouting life of the troop
and for working with the boys
and the committee is responsible
for all the
temporal aspects of it.
are we getting anywhere, David, is that helpful?
yeah, yeah, that's helpful.
you sound like you have a
Scoutmaster who was
very involved, is very involved and has
been used to doing a lot of things. is he being
resistant at all to?
yeah, he's being quite resistant,
actually, you know he's.
he was a
Cupmaster, you know, for several years before
this and he's only been Scoutmaster
now for two years. so
when he was Cupmaster he's used to doing everything.
and when he moved up to the
Boy Scout program there was nobody
to fill those roles, so he was
doing it. and now it's like, you know,
I actually have to tell him. you know, hey, that's,
you know, not your job anymore, and that's
what. it's kind of tough, you know. I don't
want to step on his toes too much, but
I don't want him to overwork himself either.
I've managed to recruit about
five or six
parents this year and
that's one of my problems is I want to make sure that
the parents have stuff to do, because
if you don't give them stuff to do, then
then the parents are going to think, well,
they don't really need me, and then
next thing, you know they're not going to want to be committee members
and help anymore, and then I'm going to be back to where I was
right. does he?
is he running the advancement?
yes, he's pretty much doing all the advancement.
we do the border reviews, but
everything else is pretty much done by the Scoutmaster.
okay, does he have? is he doing the
outdoor coordinator? is he
scheduling all that? and doing all that,
making reservations?
okay, you're the committee chairman. you need to
rest that away from him.
you need to just say: look,
I've assigned
Joe and Joe's going to be
advancement chairman and he's going to schedule
board review and here's his helper.
and when you need a
Scoutmaster after a conference,
you need a board review. you send the Scout to them
and
you know you need to,
as much as possible,
just step on his toes,
because don't, like you said,
the only way for your committee
to really take over, because
if you let it keep going,
one day he's going to quit and then you don't have
either again, you're stuck
and
it's going to take a little bit of a firm hand
if he's resistant.
but you need to take the checkbook away,
the advancement records away,
the you know, the scheduling
you know and
and the Scouts need to be talking to that
outdoor coordinator about their calendar
and the Scouts need to be talking to the advancement person.
you may actually
end up stepping on his toes slightly,
but long-term that's really the
best way to go.
ok, so if I understand this right, then the Scouts should be
coming directly to committee members then,
because I was the way it's been going lately
is they go to the Scoutmaster and then he comes
to us and tells us: you know,
I need a board review, or
no, no, no, no. the Scouts.
the Scouts go to where they need to go:
to the council or the advancement chair.
they go see the treasure if they want to turn in
to check. I mean, mom and dad can do
that, but the Scout can bring money to the
meeting Scout can go see the treasure
if they're at the meeting.
one of our rules is: the Scout always
calls for a board.
now the new
guide to advancement says that the Scout
master has to make sure that the board
happens when it's needed.
but you know, it's
great practice for them to learn to call
and make those calls
and one of the official duties of a Scout master
is to delegate. if you look
in the list, it's
delegates.
well, it's an awful
lot like the senior patrol
leader. it's not letting the senior
patrol leader do stuff and when he
doesn't delegate he
takes the opportunity of leadership
away from somebody else.
so this
guy is sort of taking
all these people and pushing
them aside a little bit.
David, have you
and your committee done any of the training
stuff yet? Yeah, all of my committee
is trained. several of them
have been around for a couple of years
as parents and
and we're on the. there were two or three
that were on the committee already and they have
the committee challenge. I think
is what it is, the training,
and I have taken that twice now.
I took it online and then
I took it. we have a once a year.
we have a program that they call it
University of Scouting, where you actually go
and it's like a day of classes
and I took the hour and a half long
person to person version because I wasn't
satisfied with the online version.
I wanted to ask some questions and
it still leaves me wondering.
you know, a lot of these roles are still
kind of left vague and you guys
have cleared it up a lot for me.
Let me pose this question: everybody,
he's got a good trained committee.
he's holding back a little bit. what do you
tell the scout master fellas to
kind of calm his nerves a little bit?
he needs to delegate to the committee,
just like he delegates
to the scouts. are his scouts
running the meetings and the camp
outs? David,
That's. that's a whole
other thing. there he's.
when I, my son and I, joined this troop
about a year and a half ago and he told
us he was going, the troop wasn't
being run boy led before
he was going to start running a boy led
and he's made some
strides towards it, but we're only about
halfway there. at this point
he's still pretty much, you know,
much to my dismay- telling the
senior patrol leader: this is what we need
to do and this is what you need to do,
and not really letting him do the planning.
and
I'm kind of gritting my teeth at that,
because it's you know he's only been at this
for a little more than a year. they're trying
to change this, so I've kind of got to have.
yeah, the delegate thing is obviously
an issue for him. Tom and Walt,
we're all in the same boat. when somebody
volunteers, it's like: go dude,
yeah, run, run as fast
as you can. the other way
is there. is there any
way that you can
go ahead and already have a
plan where
you assign these
people these tasks and don't ever
get him an opportunity to
do any of it in the first
place?
I can try and come up with something like that.
it'd be very tough. he's at
every single meeting, just about. so it's not
like you know. okay, do you have committee
meetings during troop meetings?
we don't currently. we are
talking about doing it.
currently we have one committee meeting
a month and it's
on the second Sunday of every month and our
troop meetings are on Tuesdays.
yeah, move your committee meeting to Tuesday
and he gets five or ten minutes
and then he leaves.
he goes back to his business over there
with the scouts. you know 30
or 40 successful troops, I know
really successful troops.
the committee meets during the scout meeting
and that people only make
one trip and the scout master gets
five minutes. he is not in the committee
meeting. he takes five,
seven minutes and then he's gone.
we have, we have always
we have done two separate
meetings, but I am.
I am changing. I'm trying to
get it changed to the
scout night also so that
I won't have to sit in an hour
meeting because I'm not doing
anything, I'm just sitting there. so if
I, if I have a place to go, then I'm going to
go, so and then we get some
other other adults that are sort of
hanging around with that don't normally come
to a committee meeting. we'll get some other stuff, but
I don't want to be.
I am right there with you, brother
Walter. what do you think
right? we have our committee meeting during
true meeting and it's really kind of a parent
slash committee meeting. lots of parents
show up and if the,
if the SPL needs to
go address the committee about something
right, walks over and does it.
that would be the more convenient- I'm sorry, more
most convenient thing is the
committee being there for questions
from the SPL. I think you guys have all got
the spirit of the thing just right and
hopefully that's helping you out. David,
yeah, it's a great help.
committee chairman, you do have a little
bit of authority. I don't know if you
have a commissioner,
maybe you and the commissioner- I
don't know about your chartered organization
representative- if you would
want to sit down with the scout master
and say some things. like
you know, this is how I'd like
to do things on the committee
and if you have that other person
in the room or two other people,
it's not the whole committee, but it doesn't
become you and him.
I don't know exactly how to
tell you to do that where you're at.
this could go a couple different
ways. it could
quietly start to change
things and it could lead to a kind of a
showdown too. nobody wants to see that
happen, but I mean,
I've actually pulled him aside and had
to talk with him about delegating
his authority out before,
and that was about three months
ago- and he did
let go of some of the stuff, but
a lot of stuff he still hasn't.
so that's been.
my concern is: I don't want to step on
his toes and say: you know
we're supposed to be, you know setting up
the transportation, when it's really his job
either. I don't want to be taking work away
from him, but
now that I know that you know that's really
the scouts- come to the outdoor coordinator
and
advance the chair and all that.
the way it was explained to me was:
everything flows through the scout master.
that's how it's been running in our true
the scout mat. nothing funnels
through the scout master, if at all possible.
the scout master's job is to work his way
out of a job. it's his job is to
basically do nothing but
scout master conferences
and train the SPL.
I mean, if you've got enough guys that are on the
ball, I mean you could have
a scout be the treasurer. I mean
there's nothing that says that an adult
has to do that, an adult has to supervise
it. but you know there's nothing in
the troop anywhere except driving
and maybe using a credit card
that the scouts themselves just about couldn't
do. now we don't always
get quite that far into delegating,
but you know I've always seen
my job as scout master
to get everything to the
committee in the scouts, to where I have
nothing to do but scout master conferences.
now we don't get there
and and the troop,
the boys in the troop have,
you know, over the years have had different
levels. you know I've had guys that took
almost everything. I don't know. that's kind of
how I look at it as scout master.
how about you sit down with the fellow and say,
look, you know we're both pretty new at this.
I understand your dedication
and your desire to see things
happen correctly and
and everything. but
you know we need to expand the role
of the committee,
not to take anything away
from you, but to let you concentrate
on the things that are most important to you.
I mean that might be an approach that might
help out. I found that
everything that I thought was going to happen
fast and making changes
or looking at different
ways of doing things
took a lot longer than I thought.
anything I thought: well,
you know, in six months we'll pretty much have this
by the tail
two years later. we were still kind of working at it,
but we had made some progress.
thanks for saying that.
yeah, so true,
so well, David, I hope.
I hope we helped you out there a little bit.
you helped me out a whole lot
and I think everybody here for all their
help. I really do. it was great help.
you're welcome. thanks for joining us, David,
thank you okay, bye, bye,
bye, bye.
thanks once again for participating, fellas
and thanks. thanks very much for joining us,
Walter. okay,
Larry, thanks for joining us again.
you're welcome, Clark and Tom.
thank you very much, Clark.
have a good time. thank you for joining us
and we'll see you next month.
well, thanks once again for listening to the scoutmaster podcast.
now here's how you can keep in touch.
you can read the scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom.
you can also
subscribe to the scoutmaster newsletter
and subscribe to blog
posts by email.
you can get a monthly digest
of the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster
podcast through the scoutmaster newsletter,
with some great resources
around a monthly theme.
you can subscribe to the scoutmaster podcast
on iTunes and, when you do,
please feel to leave a comment
or review a rating.
and now you can also access the podcast
on your mobile device through Stitcher smart radio
and you can get details
about that at stitchercom.
you can call and leave a voicemail, comment
or question at 4-8-4-7-3-4
0-0-0-2.
and you can also experience
the wonders of
scoutmastercgcom through the vast
panorama of social media outlets.
that's right.
you can follow us at
scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
you can tweet us at scoutmastercg
on Twitter
and for admittance to the exclusive
scoutmastercg circle,
just search for me, Clark Green, on Google Plus.
and if none of that works well,
you can always shoot me an email.
that's right, just an old
fashion email.
and you can get in touch with me at
scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet.
that's scoutmastercg
hey, everybody knows the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast.